yeah we're ready right now yeah we're
ready taste of all here ready one thing
to [ __ ] firecracker come on a shot out
here cracker a firecracker yeah I'm a
firecracker and today I'm a firecracker
I like the way you're coming at me as a
white man well as a white man who enjoys
fireworks and you said you're gonna pop
off today I don't like your lingo bro
well because I feel [ __ ] poppy first
of all these bargains Rob saw the
footage of me sparring must be on the
suspect love works how much do you pay
him $1,000 an hour Leon to let you hit
like that I do I don't know if he looks
a little bit bigger anyway but Leon is
about 270 played a d1 ball I can't
remember where that doesn't matter and
yeah we got in there and moved around
you saw me moving around you saw me it's
the Hollywood trendy thing to say that
most you and your friends say when I was
sparring right see the video it's a guy
who knows what he's doing here from that
what you careful how you talk sport let
you hit them and then you go home tell
your wife I saw my combinations disbar
you saw my combination I see it all the
time yeah box and burn I see an actor
something that in there Tony's just body
sparring with a guy goes he's round
today
top rounds like for sure man getting
better that's like that's like just
talking he was ready Rosie talking about
Sammy the bull Gravano remember he was
like John Gotti's man enforces snitch
yeah giant giant steroid user but bring
Sammy there's a lot of ultimate snitch
though he ultimately at the end he don't
like that and and and sit and I think it
was what's his name [ __ ] uh yeah he
always got in trouble back in trouble
but killed 19 people by it with his own
hands apparently a lot of times what's
the story about a little bro in boxing
so he would get in there with and
Freddie Roach would put him in it with a
guy just like me he put him with a guy
who's a real ringer a boxer and the guy
would move around and he'd let maybe it
hits you like he did tag yeah but not
hit you and then you'd hit him and he'd
cover up and so it's Sammy the bull
sitting on his doing it goes I always
had a lot more balls and brains huh
and Freddie was like this guy actually
thinks he was [ __ ] boxing him own and
and they're they're all like he actually
thinks that that guy was actually trying
and this guy was like a cruiserweight
like I was long doesn't it doesn't
matter if he's 115-pound against a
normal person they will [ __ ] you up
they will [ __ ] they will fun if you do
it every day of your life yeah if you're
not a real box yeah you'll get [ __ ] up
yeah the guys they get it you know
the guys get it they're getting paid get
it twisted but the guy who's boxing with
you is beginning is making money off you
give it and if they hurt you you're not
gonna come back correct
it's just like gonna come correct
correct and it's their job it's like you
ever seen one Jason else who he's deaf
you know he's been an actual MMA fight
and does dallas mania when he was
sparring Keith Jardine
yes I saw really went hard on key things
he couldn't excuse me and knocked him
out it was amazing it was amazing and
then knocked him clean out yeah I
couldn't believe it because he just went
yeah Haley you could see him go well you
could literally see Jardine
took a couple of shots there was a pause
I don't know if remember there was a
problem like the bar my pop-pop that's
about yeah show that show that well it
looks like when he was gonna spar uh you
know Ellis does all this crazy stuff
[Music]
like he's going hard they're trying to
whale away on him and then Jardine's
like let's not do that
look at us laughing um how about when he
was on I'm a smashing car with one hand
on it that's a terrible I remember that
because I know Shane better than anyone
he does not play like if even if you
went in the ring with Shane yeah he's
not gonna like I've seen him with it
with our old coach Trevor Whitman who
just won coach of the year
MMA award shot Trevor Whitman he would
spar with shame and he would always like
tease and make fun of him and Shane was
like dude like chill out he goes well
it's part let's figure out in the ring
like joke around and Shane broke his
[ __ ] nose with a jab [ __ ] like
shattered is no he just doesn't play no
you guys don't [ __ ] around
no and you need that and but like Butler
with with Ellis I told him like dude
Shane does not play I'm telling him with
one arm and he's gonna [ __ ] you up
I never Debbie seen that aasaiya knocked
him clean out at glove works I was
sparring with this this young well
Fabrizio's son who's 19 yeah and thin
but faster than I am and he was hitting
me he was doing this check hookin stuff
so all of a sudden we start hitting we'd
start trying to hit each other and this
sixty year old guy who teach the club
works has been he's a pro trainer and
stuff he's in [ __ ] phenomenal shape a
pro boxer himself he's stopping us whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa hey hey first of all
you two are not boxers you're here doing
this and learning and it's great nobody
here should be cracking you're getting
absolutely nothing from it and if this
becomes an ego thing that I'm not sure
what the [ __ ] you do in other words
killer you should stop of his coaching
you think that he was there Freeman was
there yeah and it was and it was so true
it was like yeah yeah take it the [ __ ]
easy unless you're getting paid you're
not you know but but I'm yes but it's
egos it's egos and I do I get I love I
love it I love seeing the actor
phenomenon of boxing everybody wants to
be a tough see my entire life everybody
wants to be a tough guy everybody wants
to get in there and do their thing and
you have a whole industry in Hollywood
that caters to that that caters to you
have real boxers who are going to
make their money by teaching you and
telling you that you're better than you
are real bit and they're not gonna talk
that's anything but just know it's with
any but just know even tennis or golf or
whatever do they think you Jitsu yeah
he's getting good ok you should see me
hit my guys hitting right at me you
should see how well I hit a ball yeah I
look great dude I'm on my toes and then
he goes let me put it over there and I
go ah well just keep it over here
okay hey keep it over here in my hit
zone yeah I'll be [ __ ] him did I tell
you when I played with deep ax d1
players he invited me out they were
hitting the boat they were there was it
was doubles and one of them was a woman
and they were hitting the ball and I I
wasn't used to that kind of topspin and
I'm not exact this was in the Arizona I
was missing the ball oh yeah it was I
got embarrassed I was missing the
[ __ ] ball they'd see me I stand I
know what people expect though you know
it's good for you though it's what they
do some people majored in sports like
you yeah and other people stopped doing
sports in high school yeah but when
they're like oh I can do this like well
well [ __ ] but I love that about that's
what I love about fighting that's what I
love about even like one time there was
a black belt and I said how did you do
against him he was a black belt in
jujitsu and you said it doesn't matter I
said when he goes he doesn't do it for a
living I did it for a living it's a big
difference now yeah what do you know I
don't care no yeah I bet have you ever
taken private lessons in anything no
never never nothing
yeah private lessons no way what about
with a personal trainer I have a
personal trainer gone I don't like that
stuff yeah you dream you train you take
care if I do so I'll just sit on my own
or watch YouTube channel you clap you
have your done classes or anything dude
I'm telling you would you would have so
much fun at 50 of the boxspring I don't
know I don't like that stuff it's just
weird there's all these girls and
[ __ ] people in shape and there's
dudes and we're waiting football when
you're when you're not saying like
there's a bunch of like it's a good I
can see it makes it more motivational
yeah see and there's music blast and you
burn a shitload of calories I should try
it at least once do it well I mean I'm
there all the [ __ ] time all right we
talked about this but we have talked
about it
we'll see I feel like Chin's the only
one doing anything for the fourth
okay what'd you do these days though
like Sochi we have kids a kin of fire
when I dropped my my kids and my wife
off at the parade my ministry you can't
have you can't have fireworks no they're
legal right I think you know most comics
there did do you go to parade chinking
you ever got a parade uh no grown man
but I can do it at I'll do that Disney
my son was like my son's like I don't
want to go to a parade
no my daughter dolled up my wife talked
about I can't wait to go to pray my
son's like I don't want to go to a
parade no I was like I don't the Disney
parades are sick though they're
entertaining yeah but what do you do on
4th besides you know my finish and I
just a [ __ ] in one of those sound public
plastic important waters porta-potties
and I didn't is my Guinea T to wipe my
rum your what use my Guinea T to wipe my
rich guineas Katie oh I'm sorry
my wife beater Oh got you and I and I
just do that away I threw that away oh
no we didn't carry it with you yeah this
was today and yeah no not today
well this is a long time ago oh I might
have [ __ ] in the sink too because I
don't want to shoot him the other thing
I don't think so but I'm in Port on
porter potty my friend took [ __ ] my
friend [ __ ] his pants
at a part at a parade when he was a
young kid his mother made him drive all
the way home on his hands and knees
because she's good she goes you can't
put your ass on the seat depends economy
so he was with a shoe with [ __ ] in his
pants he was on his hands and knees
Maxine she had drive slow because and
then she stopped and he rolled forward
and she was going don't get some your
pants and then go back and he had it was
exhausting you don't see a lot of 4th of
July did you see that guy out of 20
tournament see that guy who they caught
who was trying to blow up I think he was
in Cleveland he's gonna do it with ya he
went you know that's right that's this
but he was they caught him cuz he's on
there the FBI wanted list
he's gonna do it with remote-control
cars they caught him won't control cars
yeah he's gonna put explosive on
remote-control cars or drive it into the
parade the cottage they build the plan
I'm surprised they have no drones are
too easy they can spot drones because it
this guy's kind of explosive
remote-control cars and then that made
them they Coty's s real piece of [ __ ]
thank God I know man okay more and more
ingenious with their ways to destroy I
feel like that one's pretty there you go
cars more than one car yeah well yeah
you do work Wow
piece of [ __ ] pity us isn't living in
Ohio normal dude and then you still in
the al Qaeda dude
these people are not well you know you
just but what it's like using it 25
years maybe
all right the 25 years he gets out which
is still [ __ ] crazy
I feel like you can't do much for those
people gotta put him down I feel that
way like Isis you know in wait he's not
mine Isis and you know blow up in people
again well you don't let him out in 20
years he has a criminal record
waterboarding every day's in prison a
lot of them a lot of these people I
actually truly believe are like these
like the shoe bomber and they're just
not physically they're not they're
mentally so you got to put them in a
hospital or something like that I really
I think a lot of them are crazy that way
I don't even think you want to kill them
because they're sick so you put him in a
hospital for the criminally insane right
is that nice a maximum sentence of 20
years 20 years the dude was planning to
blow up innocent yeah civilians you know
you can't give him 20 years given life I
agree damn why do you want to agree it's
like when they they caught this dude who
was trying to kidnap juvenile girls
who's trying to kidnap you know little
girls l'm sure he had a whole kit and he
had a car and he was doing and they
matched his cell phone records and you
know in my opinion if you were trying to
kidnap little girls your life you should
go away for that right yeah don't don't
ask me because I'm gonna put a bullet
can't have them back Kevin Beckham no no
it's again don't ask me because I was a
bullet in his head because what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna go hold on it
costs how much for the taxpayer I don't
need to look you alive you're a sick dog
that I want to shoot in the [ __ ] head
have you
on the street that's yeah that's a guy
who that's a different thing for me I
don't know how to talk about guys like
that this guy who pledges allegiance
who's a cuckoo bird you know it's like
there's got to be something wrong with
his [ __ ] brain
he's also obviously not very smart if
he's posted on Facebook all Akbar and
all that [ __ ] yeah a lot of okay cool
knock you down he is a horrible track
record domestic violence robberies so
you know they say that when you look at
children there are the kids like boys
almost always almost always boys at two
years old there are certain boys that
will kick and punch and they they
enforce their way into social situations
they'll take the toy because they can
that's that's fine that's an aggressive
boy that boy has to be socialized yeah
and sometimes those kids who don't have
parents it's just what happens is they
become the people because they have that
tendency they become the two things that
go on apparently one is that they are
risk takers they don't they're not as
afraid and two is they're just naturally
very aggressive it's just a there's a
spectrum and those kids if not
socialized properly well a lot of times
go on to be socially successful no
they're actually very success criminals
yeah quarterback that's right if you if
you know exactly if you if you learn
where to play seven C's they can be CEOs
they can be [ __ ] bad yeah if it's
channelled right correct yeah you know
it's not as III believe I fail that
right you don't want to get in the back
room who's super quiet if you Ian
Charleson I think you and I have that I
mean as far as competitively or I've
always been my buddy said to me if you
weren't a great if you weren't a good
person if you didn't have a lot of
compassion for people you would have
been a good criminal I wouldn't be I can
be I've not me well I would you because
you're a mealy-mouthed [ __ ] liberal
who doesn't know what this country is
about one fourth of July and I want to
thank our veterans it's a good thing you
and you hey thank you for really all
blast on 4th of July so hot right now is
that so hot right now did you go in your
closet and go 4th of July I have let me
explain something to you you don't
understand something I asked ball not
black
underwear and my skin is white and I
have red spots Islam right a lumen
advisor Lou yeah so my psoriasis makes
me a patriot so don't tell Mom I'm sorry
did you come from a funeral where like
every day under my clothing and
long-sleeve yeah and it's a hundred 10s
I'm really hot right now dude so for the
listeners the AC doesn't work in the
studio right now so it's hot I wish I
could wear shorts luck but I just can't
I don't wear shorts a lot even for short
jean shorts I'm not very my layer I wear
shorts yeah you know when I worked out
all my shorts I don't you don't why not
I don't know
got nice leather like real tight ones
all right they're like real tight shorts
and short or long yeah I'll tell you who
doesn't want a short just Sammy Sosa
have you seen his recent interview on
the [ __ ] dirty well ESPN what's the
60 I think it's called 60 no but why is
he so white dude so he sits down with
Germany shap over the [ __ ] that guy's
name is he sits down with him give him
an exclusive interview and I thought
this German guy was so rude because he's
known Sammy has some sort of personal
relationship with him Sammy's office he
moved on and from whatever and he sits
down he's like so did you do steroids
and Sammy's like hold on my friend dick
no I never failed steroid test there's a
guy right you never failed it but
obviously you've done he's like hold on
and keeps on hold on buddy is that was
I've never failed a steroid test and
keeps poking and then sandwich goes I
I'm done thank you for being polite goes
thanks for your time he was I just want
I'm showing you at the bottom of it
people want to know do they I don't
think people want to know I think he's
moved on with his life you yeah [ __ ]
I would like to know why weasel why he's
now a white man talks about it he goes
here's what's going heroes obviously a
big thing in social media is your skin
complexion now here's what's going on
with that he goes it's a lotion I use I
like the way I look my wife likes the
way look it makes me happy I don't give
a [ __ ] what they say on the internet and
when I hear I'm like cool man do your
[ __ ] thing yeah you think he probably
his status you know in Dominican
Republic he probably always felt I don't
know I mean did he do sir it's 100
percent obviously but also who gives a
[ __ ] it's also a great baseball player
yeah I mean they're you know there's
there's stuff
Astrix you put on their good bat speed
and all that makes a huge huge
difference I mean in you know I'll see
you know he would they in they go into
it like used in the leak for whatever 16
years the first 10 he made it to the
all-star game once he's just he's just a
good player but no one really knew who
he was he comes back after some
offseason and he's like 230 pounds
jacked and he's got hit in the homerun
record I mean when I saw a superstar but
let me ask you some anyone in here or
anyone listening us right now
if so I went hey take this pill and
you're gonna go from whatever you're up
to CEO or a superstar and you're not
gonna hurt anybody
no I'll do it do it I'll do you want
even no and then also not only are gonna
do that but you're gonna go from making
a hundred thousand a year to a three
hundred million a year I was gonna just
take this shot also you get to play the
game you love for look at the difference
holy [ __ ] not only that hold on here's
the problem though one on the Left he's
21 years old the one on the right he's
34 yeah nobody blows up that much but I
know what's to go from you even if I
picture me when I was 21 to where I met
people I go that's true Jack's differ
you were really scared grown man yeah
he's a grown man now he's awfully on
steroids a ton of them yeah I always say
with baseball so your your bat speed
will stay the same or speed up and by
the way you'll play for another 7 years
that's worth another if you're him
probably a hundred but I don't know
fifty million dollars would you do it or
not like a hundred and sixty million you
can shoot me up with everything that you
did Barry Bonds is another transition I
couldn't believe god he was so skinny
back but put all of them it's like if he
ever wants to judge them and they're not
put them in Cooperstown and the Hall of
Fame stuff like that but anyone listen
if they went hey just take this you're
not gonna hurt anyone and you're gonna
get you're gonna [ __ ] be at the top
of whatever industry you yeah everyone's
gonna do it there's also like this like
I was listening to I think was Rogen's
podcast with somebody about steroids and
they were like stereo with the
testosterone or whatever you want to
call it this doesn't it's not going to
necessarily do the work for you that
there's still a lot of weightlifting so
what steroids do is allow you to recover
faster so you can train more and with
more frequency so you're gonna put on
more weight and what it does is it
rushes apparently this is I'm I'm not
gonna go into the I don't know anything
about it but it'll rush the nitrogen to
the to the muscles fasters really
layman's
doing it but you recover faster you
become muscle faster but you you
everyone just you were just into
steroids and not lift weights you jacked
no that's not true that's not true you
hear it on lean muscle I've heard too
many people talk about these guys who
talk to our coaches who dealers are like
that's like they always say the
testosterone is not gonna do the work
for you you still have to work out you
still gotta work out have your test out
like a guy like Tim Kennedy he has
levels checked and it's like through the
roof so his testosterone naturally if he
didn't lift nothing he's gonna be [ __ ]
swole yeah he's got this genetically
you're built with a frame and a muscle
musculature potential if you and Jeff
you're gonna be I'm never gonna be what
you are if you don't you could get
[ __ ] huge with Tesla yeah if I took a
lot of stuff if you don't lift at all
like you don't work out chin and I
injected you with 2,000 milligrams of
testosterone every week I promise you
chin will gain muscle he'll gain muscle
mass but you still have to work out for
you still have to work out for it to
make a huge visible as a hormone then
you don't have to words out as hard yes
yeah that's right you don't have to work
out as long or hard and you get that
that's the same there's no doubt
steroids that are transformative in
you're about a percent recent everyone
and and what here's a really important
they felt they were really work yeah
they really work but Sammy Sosa I
thought the whole thing was very strange
man I thought and also let him go miss
he says if you took Hannah boxers
without working out you would most
likely lose a little fat and perhaps
tone a little but you would not add lean
muscle mass steroids lie your body
recover and an accelerated rate but if
there's nothing to recover from then
there's no opportunity for muscle growth
right so you have to work out but it
allows you to work out you know every
day and by the way you can also eat a
shitload of food that would that and
stay lean you can eat almost anything if
you take enough of them from what I've
read and heard on Rogan and these guys
know bro science going on it's it's yeah
when I'm 16 but with with so semantics
it was like godly I don't get why they
did like how long ago is that you're
[ __ ] the guys he's trying to create
copper you give me in the Hall of Fame
he's like I don't if it happens great I
want to think about it man with my
family and the gear can be invited back
to Wrigley he's like again they invite
me great but I'm just I moved on I think
baseball's been great to me wants to see
somebody vulnerable I hate people like
that does report just a little [ __ ]
weasel you know what [ __ ] you that's him
you're like yeah you like I said you're
lucky Sammy's a nice guy
yeah most guys like the [ __ ] out of my
house that's what I was saying with you
like this guy's never done a [ __ ]
sport I can tell you that I don't get
how you can respect guys and I'm saying
over there and then they're judging
these really I mean you know much work
Sammy Sosa's done you hold you why
because as a kid he was dead broke and
they just seven get to shine shoes to
make money for his family they skate
anything about no and then you're your
legacy and this I'd like hold on you're
a little [ __ ] pipsqueak who has never
worked in your [ __ ] life like I have
I would suggest that that's why he's a
dick because he knows that and in the
presence of something i sammy sosa he
feels insecure and that prime mortally
that that exists there's like an under
tapestry that that feeling of you men do
that naturally besides each other up and
you're with a guy like that and you and
your heart know that when order breaks
down you're his [ __ ] that [ __ ]
bother certain men who've never tested
but now he almost feels like he has won
over him because obviously Sammy's
retired and now he's the interview and
you know I think it's great that I was
like oh he's a cheap shot artist that's
a cheap shot I didn't see the interview
but from what you're saying that's
[ __ ] he just keeps samia's might be
he was buddy buddy I don't want to talk
about this let's move on he just use
what the people want to know I'd be like
dude you know what get the [ __ ] out so
he did he end the interview
yeah it's a me ends it and then because
you can tell Sammy's there's a really
nice guy he comes back and goes can we
just talk about something else I don't
talk about this and he goes on to other
stuff thing goes your skin there's a lot
of debate you know what's going on with
your skin like Jesus Christ man this is
it breaking news yeah you're not you're
just doing the obvious did Sam do
steroids yes did is he put lotion on
skin yes who cares man
what do you what are you you're trying
to get a story could you make your
father guy of him doing steroids and the
way he changed his skin I would have
done this I would have said Sammy I've
always been a skinny guy I spent a lot
of time lifting and boxing I want to be
tough I'm
t1 I want to know exactly what cocktail
you were on I want you to tell me and
where do you buy your lotion cuz you
wanna go opposite you want to go black
fit I want to go a little darker yes
because I don't like I want to I want to
be able to withstand this those are the
breaking qualms more melanin my skin
those are the breaking questions those
are two things I want I want olive skin
and I want I want a couple more inches
of height even though people are always
surprised that's all I have in person
and they can tap the internet with
Germany shop is like yeah there's break
that's how you get an interview like Oh
God because that's right how many people
like that cuz imagine people who like
that yeah they're like him yeah I know
has there been any interest has there
been any like for Anthony Joshua - come
on you're below the belt seasoning a
dress he's in England yeah a fly out
here for that well he's promised sure
he'll have reason to come down he's such
a superstar I mean ya know he doesn't
really do interviews either he doesn't
know he just he went flat here for that
hmm if he was gonna fight in America
he'd come out here but rather than that
no even know if he's been here
he never leaves you who's the guy would
this never doesn't every so sing about
this there's a guy [ __ ] who was it never
fighter um or actor public personality I
think that he's got a I'd call it a very
good body but Glen are Caprio doesn't
really do interviews I love that never
he's on social media he's not as he no
there's a few guys like Will Ferrell
what they said Will Ferrell was in a
meeting with funny or dying they go it'd
be really good if kid on Instagram and
start in Twitter and stuff like can I
help promote the thing he goes if I have
to do that I quit this entertainment
business like really is like yes I don't
want to do that Wow he was you know the
Funny or Die account can create the
content and but that's all I'm gonna do
here yep music coming out some guys like
that self-promotion is tough have you
guys met Will Ferrell ever I have I
worked with him he's cool huh best movie
he's one of those guys is just such and
he's like Kevin Hart like this so those
guys you can't find anybody it's say
anything bad about ya Chelsea Handler
cuz I look for our look I asked
everybody and no one had one bad thing
to say Matthew but he
it's a nice person well we'll fill Will
Ferrell and Adam McKay in the movie
during the [ __ ] reading there was a
certain actor who wasn't they knew right
away was gonna compromise the movie it
wasn't gonna were they get rid of him
they didn't they felt bad Jesus and they
didn't want to hurt the person's
feelings that's how [ __ ] nice they
have you have you seen good someone else
yeah he's brilliant man both of them are
brilliant yeah but have you seen between
two ferns when Jerry Seinfeld's on it
ah see it's it's a brand new one it's
really green two ferns they did it I'd
like to say it's a gulf knockin Africa
so comes on but he has Jerry Seinfeld on
and Jerry's just like what you know
Jerry it's like what are we doing with
the flexible in there and then cardi B
comes in and Zacks like finally a real
celebrities current uh how you doing
Jerry's like what the [ __ ] man he's like
Jerry please let me talk to cardi B okay
we can't probably play this that's the
thing okay watch it we'll probably play
a little bit of it it's it's kind of six
minutes long I tweeted it out I'll just
chop it we clicked on last time and
they'll have this guy
yes it's like I love the 90s I might as
well have lorena bobbitt as a guest yeah
but Lorraine came up with weekly or ten
people have legitimate guests hi my name
is zach galifianakis welcome to another
edition of between two ferns my guest
today is jerry sandusky
fast I felt Jason is drilled to be here
seems like everyone from the Seinfeld
cast has gone on to do you know great
wonderful stuff Elaine is on VP Emmy
Award winner and Kramer did that great
stand-up bit for whites cardi thank you
so much for coming by and saving the
show cardi B everybody thanks for coming
thank you so much Karen curse he's toast
it's toasty so toasty well we just
watched between two ferns were back
money right a nice little like yeah I
was very good he's great they're elated
Zack makes me laugh to staring him Zack
and Jerry Seinfeld and cardi B that's
what got me we were in his house one
time back in the day before I think was
before the hangover and he was like said
something and he goes well that's funny
and his house is being renovated me he
took out a pen and wrote the joke on the
wall Jesus
he was quiet quiet like it's hard for me
to write jokes I'm taking an acting
class online yet so he took a break a
little bit so I asked someone he's been
doing he's like sometimes it breaks the
best thing is that you're only talked
about embracing the hustle yeah
sometimes you need a big ass break yeah
he doesn't he's one of those guys who
truly doesn't like Fame like he would go
to when we were in Thailand he would
walk he'd like walk into neighborhoods
and just disappear in Bangkok just cuz
nobody bothered him yeah but yeah like I
want to the fish market the lady boys at
her ass yeah yeah no harass you alright
I'd like to go to Thailand Thailand trip
yeah I'll do that with you so far oh
well I you know I flew first class and
it was too far and it was too far and I
was like get
well you stopped in Japan and so I think
it was a tank it'll drag was too long
chin how far is it was too long it was
so long one stop there Alton there's no
direct 17.3 oh and how far was
australian 1414 yeah I had a better Tina
fortune
Australia wasn't too bad yeah I had a
better good JA minute gin soldier back
there were you Chin's one of those tough
[ __ ] though channel Stood Still and
probably this awesome time dude
station how long ago was doesn't feel
like Australia was nine years ago it
does it was last year but England we did
England Australia yeah that feels like
why don't we go do in your whole
headliner thing in Australia it'll be
fun
I'd love to why not yeah you know I mean
yeah wouldn't it be a good time it's fun
out there
well you know I messed up this time
because you know I I don't like to be
gone the way that long for my son but I
[ __ ] up cuz chin and I would go find a
Sydney we'd have no time to say anything
cuz I have to take a red-eye in the next
day to Brisbane tan one night in
Brisbane fly from Brisbane to [ __ ]
Perth or wherever the [ __ ] we were in
New Zealand in Auckland
one night there fly the next morning to
back to Sydney like we didn't get see
[ __ ] do we Chen well we've got to see
kangaroos we got off the plane and
chilled with kangaroo that was it it was
a when I went out we do 45 minutes each
and then we do a Q&A afterwards
what about q and A's but yeah yeah it's
kind of cool took you guys might get
tiring yeah um do a show but I would do
it and I would do it I do like three
shows in Sydney I just picked two cities
I'd do three shows in Sydney and then
three shows in Auckland or something
like that and then but do it a week so
you get experience the cities I didn't
get the a [ __ ] yeah he'snot was so nice
and the what was the guy's name who
helped us cricket we call him shrimp
shrimp a cricket he's a beef right
shrimp was he small no he but he worked
with
everybody like these huge bands man he
was like we'd go through security like
they're a shrimp you're good and we'd go
straight to the brow great guys I'd only
do it with him matter of fact he's I go
back nature I have all new material will
you do that
boom love it do international national
hey is it cool if I put my meat on your
grill for the fourth what does that mean
dude what do you mean probably don't
like because you were Rumble questions
into the mic simple question you why
can't I make my meat on your grill for
the fourth of July it's not a simple
question because you might be asking me
something and you're trying to lure me
into a trap and I'm not and I put my
meat on your grill if you want to bring
some meat over to my grill mmm and you
want to slap it on the grill yes after
it's been seasoned yes and if you want
to roast it till it's toasty huh and the
less used to screw it up
they're cool if the meat is juicy its
juicy and the meat will probably drip
the white meat
so if you want to put pork and chicken
on the grill it's a white meat bro on
your grill my white meat that I know I
belong to turkeys chicken pork so if you
have turkey chicken or pork and I want
to be very specific about this and you
don't mind if the juice is running your
mouth it's a juicy piece of meat you're
cool with it
then you can bring your meat to my place
okay so I got my grill so I can put my
juicy piece of meat on your grill yeah
but I
I feel like Europe being I feel like
you're being mischievous and I don't
feel like you're being upfront and I
feel like you're being metaphorical are
you talking about your dick on my
quote/unquote grill that's in my mouth
until the juices squirt out because I
think that's offensive because they
don't know that dude this is a mom bro
the greatest name in 14 what I'm saying
yeah can I put my card in your [ __ ]
stupid human mouth and buy juices I mean
can I calm down your throat I
okay so forth so I don't know Sarah I
can't be
that's what you're as mind if I take
this white card
hurry set goal [ __ ] your cooking took it
if that's what you're saying then the
answer unequivocally on July's the
holidays is you can but you better not
be smiling they'll do it alright
browning and screaming I'm not gay the
whole time hey I bet you don't know how
to grill you don't look like your grill
guy not a grill guy no and I said I and
to make my wife laugh I go there's a
problem like the door is like you know
stuck and I go I'm gonna get my tools
and fix that you just not like you're
not like any man anything but like you
know you know I can make a rack of ribs
I don't have my special barbecue sauces
and all that [ __ ] no I'm not a real man
I'm just not who can I'm not enjoying
I'm not even the father that like you
know the the tires were the tires were
my daughter I'm oh I've wanted to go
bike riding and the tires were flat you
know I and I had to try to find the pump
and then I wasn't doing it right and my
wife went kick get out of the way get
out away just she moves me out of the
way and put the Banshee [ __ ] you that
night
she doesn't [ __ ] me dude no no I'm
saying she doesn't [ __ ] me you know I
lay it down the way I box a [ __ ] the way
I box
you saw my combinations not a see
anything you could give me a little
credit for my combos
nope I can't all right umm genius of
current events idea before we pass out
from he discussion it is so hot so I
know what okay there's no one why is the
door shut I don't know
oh no wiser shut because I'm afraid if
someone just randomly walking in oh shut
up I'm open you can open a door I open
the door by the way it'll make no
difference but still we just heard
someone next door is it better at all
new shirts wow those are great
Metallica style too tight I want that
good is that mine is that a medium
though yeah
that's perfect I love that name I love
it boom alright first current event is
4th of July related Joey Chestnut set a
new world record for seventy four hot
dogs eaten in ten minutes
space hot dog contest it's just his
third straight win in 11 and 12 years
man semi for hot dogs in 10 minutes
their video is he dumped it into water
yeah of course let me see there's a
width the bun like where yes
[ __ ] yeah bro it's a hot dogs but he
just swallows all of them you but you
dip some water to soften and deep
throats the hot dogs it's kind of nasty
god there's an I like hot do you like
hot dogs
what's that we can all be frank yeah
there's nothing with a little sauerkraut
yes yes I might cook some of those today
see it's disgusting it's so gross cuz
they wet it and then they just scarf it
down
dude he's beaten the [ __ ] out of the
rest of the people who there's there's
never they're never like fat guys like
Maricopa Kobayashi was yeah he got
ripped I picture something somewhere
here just just in case you guys wanted
to see him we mean you have pictures of
me well I like to load it up yeah
Kobayashi was that's that's Kobayashi
before when and he was his biggest rival
in the beginning and then Kobe I started
weight training and then go really
skinny booze and taking lots of stairs
yeah so does he still eat hot dogs for
he hasn't shown up no right I'm not sure
why but impressive cuz doctor being
skinny in oh it's back to being skating
yeah back to being skinny I know he
doesn't eat hot dogs anymore but he
looks like he did right I'm not gonna
say anything that's so funny says
there's a picture here of him
oh and there's nothing wrong that he's
acosta Father's Day never mind this his
dad and his dad was [ __ ] retired
piece his dad yes yes yes I would say so
instead of putting away hot dogs in the
mouth
to that without question he's I'm not
sure if it's a competition for him
anymore but I'm sure there's a lot doing
sexy young lady and there's nothing
wrong he went from its you would think
it was like big fat guys who [ __ ] those
competitions up the world competitions
though I think our fat guys you've seen
the wing guys wings now first of all you
got bones oh really
there's not one fat guy there how do
they all look at the old man oh my god
oh that's depressing it's so depressing
how do you price tree mean eating
contest it's disgusting seeing people
even like this for career I agree smell
a little different while they're hot
I love a good chicken wing there is
anything better than chicken my mouth is
watering well the reason that redhead
Beasley Bourdain with it with the chef
they were doing this thing on on peppers
I think they were in Thailand those
members yes he goes you like to be
spanked and chef goes I don't know you
guys you like to have somebody take a
whip and beat you until you scream for
mercy and he goes I don't he goes but
you like to be beaten in the submission
with a with a Chile right you want
chillies you want just them to destroy
your mouth he goes I do your green yeah
just to be something about some like
when my girl's family makes like Mexican
salsa like a real Mexican salsa you have
habaneros it's so hot my mouth to go
numb and I'm like but you can't stop it
I can't no I definitely stop eating it I
can't taste anything yeah like I don't
get the point I don't want you at who
that doesn't really bother me because I
can't taste anything but then you so
there's Mexican art then there's Thai
hot hot circuit IATA even above that
like you go to a traditional Thai
restaurant you see Thai hot it will fuch
you're like II need a whole habanero
pepper and I've done it I can eat two
whole hop yeah there's the Thai hunt
yeah Thai I had a Thai pepper and it was
unbelievable oh you know folks with time
job you know I play singles he goes
he'll his friend Buster who's always
with us on the road I see him hooked oh
is this a traditional Thai play
Buster goes pretty traditional huger
than Thai hot please it's not Thai hot
he's like I need to make as hot as
possible Wow very strange very very
strange for a gringo I used to be able
to do that now at 51 that should all go
right through me
they say spicy food helps burn calories
and shit's good for you
it also apparently keeps you awake
longer so like when when on the campaign
trail Hillary Hillary Clinton said I
don't get a lot of sleep but I eat a lot
of peppers it'll resonate it's true keep
your [ __ ] she also passed down yeah so
what else get gin all right so this
video right here this was going viral
it's about a black woman being pulled
over by a bunch of different cops and it
looks like she's innocent she has like
no gun in her hand I'll play it for you
first right there's has to be some back
stairs okay so the guy that's recording
Saints in West Hollywood Inglewood
a bunch of cops with guns drinks
Frappuccino yes you got one get two
they're all got their guns oh there's a
reason for that yes yes
La Cienega and said to Milla setting the
world yeah well it was shot in Inglewood
okay so you can see right there 3.16
million views and then look at all the
likes eighty six thousand nine hundred
and the people just like these cups here
we go this is backlash like crazy now
give this real story why there do check
this this is why this is weird time Jim
so this girl her name is Daisy McCracken
she's actually an old friend of mine she
is yeah we haven't talked innocent ears
no no bro I'm serious okay no we never
dated but that when I do I graduated
from audio engineering school the first
album I worked on was hers
oh yeah I was with her every single day
I actually know her so she was kidnapped
from her home in LA by some people from
Compton that girl is tied to those and
heard the guy that she was with got
kidnapped as well he was trying to
protect her they tortured him I guess
they maimed part of it some part of his
body they didn't say exactly why yet and
then kidnapped like kept him in the
bathroom for 30 hours with no food and
just naked did he die he didn't die but
he's disfigured somehow they did some
crazy [ __ ] turns just yeah it's a good
money so that was the reason why they
did that so obviously if you feel hard
of that she's she's tied to them so
there's three people she had a worn out
for a run yeah they don't have all those
that manpower there without that there's
a reason they're not there you know and
that's a reality
[ __ ] kidnapping Jesus Yeah right she
escaped completely why were there so a
bunch of thugs from Compton kidnapped
these two people they went to LA to
kidnapped and like in Hollywood a shop
oh I forgot exactly where was its thing
South it is that's scary man
so they kidnapped him and then brought
him back to Compton
yeah and they held him hostage in their
house yep [ __ ] that's scary man how why
would they pick them out it's not like I
don't know they're not okay so they're
actors she's an actress she did the
Hollywood Halloween resurrection but
nothing like huge movies right that's
the more so much seek him
they're fun right yeah cuz they're got
your case they probably watched them go
get money from them because they're rich
hmm that's a capital offense we'll see
you later South Los Angeles I don't know
where South watchin that was yeah South
LA might be near you know Compton those
areas like so there's West LA and South
LA is is where that's I could leave them
place bags with two victims heads and
drove them several miles to their homes
in Compton okay so several miles that's
the west side man yeah they didn't know
they were on they were that south they
were they were I think they were
probably living on note they were
probably living on Adams so if you go to
10 East let's do that area that's South
LA though if you go it'd be definitely
right it's on the way to downtown yes
Adams they're not living in Alf Adams it
sounds like South LA go go to where
South LA is Adams rough cuz I Drive
downtown all the time yeah it is Adam
those pits also really nice though you
can also get really good houses and
people are buying them up there that's
in Inglewood
oh it's Inglewood yeah so just seemed
roughly rough area Rangel is always
notorious they've been a rough area it's
getting better yeah because their
property values - they're building that
stadium Dingle it's not no joke no and
and hold on for a second let me see come
to you look at where Compton is so it's
in with Ben that's just a heavy gang
area so they must have just drove past
them or something I think they got cased
I think they saw they have a lot of
people buying houses in that area so
because they have really beautiful old
houses they're from old LA and and those
houses are going for a lot of money now
in Inglewood so and a lot of people I
move in there you get a lot of bang for
your buck they're scary yeah so in that
situation you have to put guns on them
and everything torturing their
kidnapping torturing people [ __ ] man
yeah what does she alright
oh this is for Brian since your favorite
girl is Jessica Chastain so the it's
sequels coming out I'm not sure next
year so two years from now
but it's gonna be the adults this time
love there's Jessica Chastain she's
brilliant so it's gonna be Bill Hader
James McAvoy which I am is not following
James McAvoy is that guy from a splice
not splice was this place split
oh he's brilliant the guy plays all the
different characters yeah that's James
yeah yeah well there's that so cool man
Bill Hader monster that's really cool
cool hate for that and then sad news
Halsey and gez split do they say why no
who are they he's a famous white rapper
and she's a really famous singer Brendon
always talks about this guy cuz he wears
floral cool floor for he's she's just
super hot and then she's big time into
thing in right now she's pretty there
huh and she posts something like you
know kiss you kiss your dog gets my dog
in the forehead and then kiss your ass
good-bye oh my god I didn't see that
yeah nasty because look they said here
she wishes the best fun yeah what can I
do only the other year of course it
didn't work out what else yet oh this is
one heaven may one up
so apparently UFC had a record year last
year 2017 their earnings as far as how
much money they made Wow so over 700
million Jesus yeah but did that Conor
McGregor fight yeah exactly that's the
biggest reason why yeah well Conor
McGregor they got half of his [ __ ] so
there's a lot going on there still
surprising to me at least I'm sure it
says something with that yeah they
definitely mentioned the Conor McGregor
thing being a big reason why yeah but
that's and also to hunt 17 so did round
2 fight to on 17 I don't think so Brock
Lesnar did right I think it was to 16 I
don't know but I'm sure they make you
they also make a shitload of money off
fight path get the biggest the biggest
draws our Lesnar consistent Conor number
one yeah so he didn't fight 2017 oh well
good for them been yeah surprising that
is scary a lot of money
seven million hmm oh yeah yeah and this
is a few days old but I'm sure you guys
seen this already the burglary I'm not
the per query I'm sorry
so they used these two people use a
stolen credit card to buy like us just a
soda can and maybe some popcorn er
somebody died
and then G the owners of the liquor
store felt like there's something shady
about these people so it was it turned
out that the the card was stolen okay
cops got called over and then the series
of every all the events that happen are
just funny I haven't seen this so all of
you they play it
they made it viral because they want
they put it with the Benny Hill music so
you can see all the different angles so
right there he's pushing the girl on to
the cop so he can leave and he runs
through the back cops holding them
top was given is that taser taser yeah
and then she's trying to help
then he tase him cuz he actually went
for him yep tased them down and now the
girl is trying to bounce so she well she
tried sleeping the bull fast asleep well
I mean the guys taste now oh damn the
guy gets up avoids the job that's pretty
good yeah the girl goes in the back it's
locked
climbs up holy [ __ ] she's trying to hide
she's trying to hide in the roof it must
be junkies the ceiling managed boom she
falls out of the ceiling oh my god she's
crawling dude they're relentless
impressive it's inspiring it's now
there's 19 cops if you hope that you can
hold a job we see a mug shot of those
two I wanted to see what they look like
he's got no shirt on Canadian
convenience store killer [ __ ] you hardly
where's that us in Canada Oh Canada
great junkies quiet Vancouver all due
respect to Vancouver there's a junkie
there's that there are neighborhoods you
know you make the wrong turn nobody has
teeth there's zombies you know I mean
Vancouver you know I mean you got the
wrong like you're like oh what is this
Street The Walking Dead God I'll first
well get stolen credit card you can't be
doing that but Jesus Christ man I guess
they're not available might be her there
she is hi sweetie she fell out of the
roof yeah well what better choices yeah
they said a choice has you dum-dums well
this is a little old one but I thought
this is pretty cool
so this guy who was an insurance
salesman decided to lose weight just to
be more healthier and that I've grown a
beard and then became a model oh great
look at that that is so [ __ ] cool
totally I'm EPA is that hey sign me up
for Game of Thrones yeah damn right he
is dude his hair is gorgeous
it sure is he's got a look at that he's
a Viking that's what made him famous
that's what that's the scalp
found him because of his beard he did it
because he thought it'd be funny to grow
a ginger beard wow he's a model that's
him before Oh what wha
hold on well done sir well done the
things oh I guess his friend said if
you're gonna play guitar you should grow
a beard he goes that'd be funny if I
grew a ginger beard and then you got
discovered yeah so I washed with David
Beckham Ceylon David Beckham's uh he's
one of his lines 99 house 19 I think it
is here now fantastic
don't let anyone tell you you can't do
anything look at that [ __ ] dude dude I
got a grown man I'm he's still redhead
so I judge him but he's got some real
hair I'm still red he's also turning
like oh my god was that Jen I gotta get
myself that's just the end of it I'm
gonna dye my hair bread Jesus Christ
good for him in yeah he's from corporate
life to dimepiece lie damn right buddy
hey let me shushing you she you talk
about you and yet winning yeah that was
a good shake right you watch that game I
do I got two roadies and I told Jamie I
go dude turn the goddamn game on for me
I went to penalty kicks and Rogin walks
in you let's start to think your routes
like I'm like kind of do man kind of do
can we just wait can he not care about
the World Cup
yeah are you out of your mind dude [ __ ]
yeah England yes right let's bring it
home great that was ringing hello boys
great hard my [ __ ] England Jersey a
long time taking forever talk about
pressure for those goalies holy [ __ ] I
wrote because I lost time that's the
hardest thing is sports to stop that and
everyone's [ __ ] TMI like no there's
no expectations for the goalie you guys
are missing my point
just cuz there's no expectations and
he's not expected to stop any goals gets
impossible it's still very [ __ ] Tom's
gotta get he's got a guess and theirs
but their point is well there's not that
much pressure cuz no one expects him to
stop it I'm like yeah I know a lot of
pride but still no one expects guys at
home run yeah the chances are very slim
let them stop it well because it's the
odds it's so hard or not okay yeah so
the goalie it's not like thawing his
head if they Luke got you know it still
if he stops it's like oh [ __ ] em you
know yeah that's right baby England my
boy Harry Kane
it was really awesome and how about
Swede in the country of what eight
million crushing it in the quarterfinals
first time since night they beat Mexico
right somebody beat him Switzerland
yeah and but they also be Mexico three
to nothing right nothing so Mexico's out
now nice to go loss to Brazil but I mean
Sweden I talk about Vikings I mean
you're talking about a very small
country with a very small population to
draw from and they crush it and not a
lot of time outside they have to play
indoors
oh no it's cold yeah that's why they're
very light skin - it should be tough
asset for anyone to be Brazil but I hope
your way does I hope it's Uruguay versus
another country have 2.8 million people
or why would why so if they beat Brazil
that's huge it's so so was it is it it
was gonna now it gets so fun with there
are no games today
no they don't start back up to what
Friday maybe why is it not till next
week now in the quarterfinals yeah yeah
Friday you're away France please win
that usually Sweden eaten England Russia
Croatia could give two [ __ ] about any
of those and then Brazil Belgium but as
you so the winner of Sweden England will
play the winner of Russia Croatia
England can do that and then Uruguay
France play the winner of Brazil Belgium
I think the winner of Brazil Belgium
will make to the finals
Brazil is gonna be [ __ ] tough to beat
how did they they made some serious
changes after that humiliating defeat
against Germany on have no idea yeah who
they got embarrassed by Germany in the
last World Cup hello let me change the
since lastest moment for Brazil can
organize what else get chin Rachel
Dolezal is better oh my god she was
arrested but she's released now but
rested and booked you remember were be
don't she was the one was it Vancouver
Seattle Seattle
I don't remember on the in a mouth she's
black yes there's a whole dock on
Netflix which is amazing on just they
follow her life and what happened this
guy's the interviewing goes I'm sorry
you your pair
but you don't look back just well I'm
black sweetie and then they look into it
like your parents are white white she's
like wow but when you hear the stories
you still doing right now she's still
like she's oh that's a 2017 photo she's
still doing
she's darkening or scanning yeah but
well she looks even darker now and Tom
with that but the problem is like when
you when you see like like her
upbringing why she responds that way and
her horrible upbringing and how her her
family adopted these these black kids
her brothers and sisters and she like
felt more closer to them than her white
pants and there's a normal stuff a
little bit strange yeah but if that's
what makes her happy who gives up same
with Sammy Sosa are we up in arms that
same so it's turning white no I mean
it's a it's a if you want paying
yourself purple I do not give a [ __ ] the
problem is with her you know but also
she was the head of the NC double-a CP
on teaching what was she teaching
African American Studies yeah under the
under a pretext but she wasn't so what
you were to she was helping the cosmos
you didn't they but but you're still
you're still you're still benefiting
from a certain form of legitimacy that
is not up front so if the students and
people are taking your class the NCAA is
taking I'm not NC double-a then SS n
double acp is is putting you in a
position of leadership because you have
experienced what it is to be
african-american in the United States
which according to their credo and
according to you know it would probably
play a significant role in whether or
not those people choose you're putting
on your presenting a false narrative and
you're not being a front with who you
really are so in a way you're being an
imposter so that's where I think that's
why people burbs yeah that's where you
have to kind of like you have to take
her to task because she was not being if
you watch the documentary a you're like
alright I get what she's doing it
doesn't make it right but also like you
feel subs before yeah
but B you also find out she's a Fame
[ __ ] there's nothing cuz they're kids
like please mom stop with the cameras
and she just keeps doing oh yeah
interesting so see there's nothing like
I think that you're being compassionate
to
who's got this identity issue I don't
give a [ __ ] if you want to have surgery
on your eyes so you look Asian and
that's your thing I dunno oh yeah has
ever done that I guarantee to an extent
that's a style choice but I think in
this case she benefited from being a
black woman and was given positions of
influence under false pretext and the
people that put her a solid she's doing
wrong my only thing is she was help if
she was lying to them she was yes it
doesn't matter you're still lying you
know and so people will call you on that
which is which is fair whoa Jesus crazy
College I know that's a person once
looked like an Asian Kylie Jenner I
don't know well whatever that [ __ ] works
uh everything's been done yeah sure what
else you got that's basic man goes under
the knife till occasion do you think
should have clicked on that one chair I
think they just I'll forward where did
it go Brock Lesnar
here we go Korean of course such people
are gonna they did they do po I will so
you don't look Korean he just looks like
look like it animate here
doesn't look real she says mental
illness the nose in helping anybody who
crazy took it pinch off the tip of the
nose there well she got you that's it
now I don't think there's much else well
so speaking of surgery I'm having people
to wish me a fourth of July
not one person has been glorious good
for you been super gloriously more
people that's new on this podcast yes ah
come see me in Tampa this weekend guys
seriously
Friday Saturday guide Susie budgie holy
fourth of July weekend but let's get
serious
I'm Friday Saturday and then I'll be in
Syracuse I'll be at Gotham comedy club
June I mean July 12th and in the 13th or
14th of July I'm at Syracuse with the
funny bone come and see me there
apparently I'm hilarious live and also
I'll be a well and we know what goes on
the 19th of the 20th Italia hall still
maybe some tickets left on the 19th but
I don't I don't I'm not sure Chicago
Chicago I will be there buddy
Saturday Oklahoma I think those tickers
sold out but check T fetch a calm and
next week I'm and spoke and washed and
get them and then Austin the first week
of August and second week of August I am
in Dallas teeka's at T fat K calm go get
them for Brian and myself happy fourth
of July of filthy animals this is the
final kid we're out